Brandon had to do
problems 45 through 75
for homework tonight.
If Brandon did all
of the problems
he was assigned, how
many problems did he do?
So there's a
temptation here to just
say, well, what is 75 minus 45?
So you might say, hey, 75
minus 45 is equal to 30.
Maybe he did
exactly 30 problems.
But we have to be very,
very, very careful here.
And to understand why we
have to be careful here-- so
let me put a question
mark right over here.
To realize why we have
to be careful here
is imagine-- let's do
some smaller numbers
so that we can really
count things out.
So let's say instead
of 45 through 75,
let's say he had to do
problems 3 through 6.
If we use this technique
that we just did up here,
we would say, well, 6
minus 3 is equal to 3.
Maybe he had to do 3 problems.
But let's actually count it out.
So there's problem 1, problem
2, problem 3, problem 4,
problem 5, problem 6.
He's going to have to do problem
3 through 6, including problem
3.
So he's going to do problem 3,
problem 4, problem 5, problem
6.
When I subtract 6
minus 3, I'm really
only caring about
problems 4, 5, and 6.
I'm looking at how much do I
have to go to go from 3 to 6.
I'm not including the actual 3.
So really, when he's doing
problems 3 through 6,
he's not just doing 6 minus 3.
He's doing 6 minus 3 plus 1.
He's actually doing 4 problems.
And you could do this
with multiple scenarios
to realize when
you just subtract,
you're not counting
the very first problem.
You're just counting all the
incremental ones after that.
So to answer this question, if
he's doing problems 45 to 75,
it's not enough
just to subtract.
That won't count the
first problem, the 45th.
You actually have to add 1.
So in this case, Brandon
does 31 problems.
Let's do another
counting problem.
A baker has a whole
loaf of bread.
How many cuts must he make to
have exactly 7 even slices?
Well, you could work
this one out directly,
trying to cut a slice of bread.
But let's think
about even if there
were 70 even slices,
a much larger number.
Well, we could do a
little loaf of bread.
So that's our loaf of bread.
If you want 2 slices, how
many cuts do you make?
Well, you only make 1 cut.
2 slices, you only make 1 cut.
What if you wanted 3 slices?
So if you wanted 3 slices, how
many cuts do you need to make?
Well, you make 1 cut,
and you make 2 cuts.
So you make 2 cuts, and I
think you see a pattern here.
If we want 4 slices, how
many cuts do we make?
Well, 1, 2, 3 cuts,
so it's 3 cuts.
And you could go all the way
to 7, but you see the pattern.
However many slices
you want, you only
need to do that many
slices minus 1 cuts.
So for 7 even slices, you
only have to do 6 cuts,
and you see why.
You don't have to cut
out that very last piece.
It just falls off the edge.
Let's do one more of these.
Ishaan is building a straight
fence with posts 1 meter apart.
If the fence is 18 meters
long, how many fence posts
does he need?
Well, we use the same idea.
Let's do it with a
smaller situation.
Let's imagine a
2-meter-long fence.
For a 2-meter-long fence, he's
going to have 1 fence post.
Then the fence is
going to go a meter.
Then he's going to need
another fence post.
Then the fence is
going to go a meter,
and then he needs
another fence post.
So if you compare it
to the cutting bread,
you have your cut,
but you also have
to do the ends right over here.
So for a 2-meter fence,
he needs 3 posts.
What about for a 3-meter fence?
Well, you're going to have
to have the first post.
You go a meter of fencing.
Then you have the second
post, a meter of fencing.
You have the third post,
but you're not done yet.
Then you have another
meter of fencing.
And then you need to have
the end post right over here.
So you see you need 4 posts.
You essentially need 1 post at
the beginning of each section,
and then you need
1 to finish up.
So what you see here
is however meters,
you're going to need
that many plus 1 posts.
So here, if you're
going 18 meters,
you're going to
need 19 fence posts.